since King Charles is in Germany on his
first state visit as Monarch he's in
Berlin for a three-day trip with the
queen consort Camilla The Royals are
receiving military honors at the
Brandenburg gate and will then attend a
state banquet at the German presidents
at Bellevue Palace
well for more on that we're joined by
Ulrich Bruckner he's a political
commentator and the Jean Monet Professor
for European studies at Stanford
University in Berlin or Rick this is
King Charles's first state visit abroad
I remember when Queen Elizabeth was
crowned she taught the Commonwealth so
this child's this trip for Charles is
meant to be for France and then Germany
but it's starting in Germany this is
really about communicating that Europe
is a priority here
well I think it was a good idea to come
to Germany and not to Paris that would
only produce pictures of garbage and
burning barracks and turbulances and
also the meeting of someone who's
criticized to be a French Emperor
meeting a British king would certainly
be not what France Noir Britain would
like to see in comparison with Berlin
this is a pretty stable and also calm
situation and a lot of Germans warmly
welcomed the visit of the king I'm
sitting here in a university three
blocks away from the hotel and runbook
gate and it's not so much of a deal
because Royals are interesting for
people who read tabloids but for
everyone who reads it as a political
signal it's a positive sign well King
Charles obviously has some family ties
to the country and I believe he also
speaks a bit of German how's he being
received is he as popular perhaps as his
mother
yeah
well he's certainly not as popular as
his mother and I think also the bad
stories that everyone could follow if
one is interested in the royal family in
the last few years also didn't really
boost the reputation of the king I think
generally speaking Britain suffered a
lot from brexit and the reputation of
the country not only that they moved
away from the European Union but also
that pretending that Global Britain is a
better solution than the European Union
broke people's hearts and they are
rather distant to everything that comes
from the United Kingdom well is this
then a moment to try to amend some of
those ties are Germans and German
politicians open to that
they certainly are and I think it showed
during the pandemic as well as with the
ongoing war in Ukraine that standing
alone and pretending that states can
respond to Global challenges that are
far bigger than what a single country
can manage that these times are
different and we should only stay United
and not only pretend that the West is
United but also work on Mutual
understanding and symbolic actions like
visiting each other is an important step
in that direction I see that King
Charles is also during this three-day
trip he'll be speaking to the bundestag
how is the British royal family regarded
there does this still have relevance for
Germans in this day and age
I don't think they put too much
importance to the symbolic actions but I
just talked to some of my colleagues and
they were complaining that they didn't
get a chance to get into the bundestag
to listen to it so there is quite some
attention to what's going on but after
all he's a king and he's visiting a
republic and although we don't have a
king we very much appreciate that our
president acts as something like a
republican King steinmeier in the castle
and so there is a certain emotional
relationship with royal families and so
on but after all it's a western type
democracy and one understands that he's
sent by the prime minister of Britain to
pave the way for closer relations and
indeed they will be discussing those
over dinner at the Bellevue
um Palace this evening or Rick Bruckner
there a political commentator speaking
to us from Berlin always great to keep
your thoughts or Rick thanks for joining
us
thank you